so I have two comedians this is our job
more than anything else is to is to get
to that line and figure out where it is
and push it may be cross it every now
and again I think we live in a very
bizarre time where we have trigger
warnings now and social justice warriors
and every time anyone says anything
about you say something bout women they
don't like that you're now you hate
women you say something about any
minority you don't like are you saying
about gay people you automatically hate
all of them that we automatically jump
to the conclusion that it's based in
racism or xenophobia especially for
comedian this is a seriously dangerous
slope right you know is the worst with
that the Puerto Ricans watch yeah you
watch no I honest yeah yeah I don't
think it's so much about PC culture I
just think everyone has a knee-jerk
reaction people are like this now why
are people like this now everyone is so
angry and no one just wants to enjoy
jokes or have fun anymore every
everything has to be a purpose like now
they have the new normal Barbie it's a
Barbie doll that has stretch marks and
pimples a normal Barbie and that's it
right I did you know why can't people
just have toys not reading a million
things why does everything have to have
a hundred percent purpose or you know
you mean be without any humor anymore
don't you think that that actually takes
something very special away from
childhood that you know I played with GI
Joe or he-man or transformers and the
imagination I got to use my imagination
to make up this world and you know
figure out things that I thought and
whatever we're now you're gonna make
everything so realistic for these kids
and away to them of every fear and
everything that might upset them that
you're gonna send a bunch of robots and
by the way they're drug right they're
all on every drug known to man because
of you know whatever that we're going to
send them out into a world drugged and
afraid of everything that's pretty
dangerous combination right you know
getting back to the PC thing you are
correct that some people are two
knee-jerk and cry racism or and whatever
anti-semitism oh sure and there is so
that's the thing that's where it's like
murky press you're like well I don't
want to get into a point where we just
shout
so now because the right wing does a
thing where they shall every time there
actually is racism they go oh you're
just 2pc no that's not being to pc right
so that for example that would be when
the right will say that Christians are
actually the most under attack in
America which is of course when are the
Christians gonna have their day in
America Dave someday they're gonna have
a guy maybe in the White House yeah to
run things so yes you know the thing
that Jerry Seinfeld right so that came
up with he was complaining about PC
culture on campus Ivan colleges in a
year but I oh I mean in a couple of
years but i noticed when i used to play
colleges that the higher the tuition the
more freedom I got to say whatever I
wanted and it was interesting yeah so
the lower the tuition you know I don't
know if the Dumber the kids or whatever
I don't know I want to she's very
politically incorrect I know that's
politically incorrect so I went to shoot
E school and I'm a dumb guy so i can say
that and uh to look up where I went yes
equity Yale the point is it sucked
George Bush went there yeah that whole
thing trigger war yes yeah it's crap I
when I first four of course yes there's
gonna be someone who reads something and
it's gonna them up well you can't
pass a law about it yeah you know that's
their own problem they have to deal with
you know what I hear what are your car
horns I freaked out I can't pass a law
that says nobody can beat their horn
anymore right so is the bigger fear I
used to fear that the first amendment
would disappear that the government
would take our free speech but what I'm
starting to fear now although i am no
big fan of the government in any
capacity what I'm starting to fear now
is that ultimately we're just gonna take
our freedoms away we're gonna get so
afraid of saying anything and I see this
happen all the time now I get emails not
that I'm the most politically incorrect
person there is but I get emails now
people saying that I'm saying things
that they wish they could say and it
seems to me that people are censoring
themselves already so I fear that I fear
the self-censorship because of all the
yes more than I fear that the
government's going to come in and take
away our right to free speech to you
where do you where do you fall on it
well all I want to say this I was just
working Vegas last week and I there was
one set where I was having it was a
little the crowd was tight and a guy was
sitting with his arms crossed and I for
15 years of I said oh you know our
intervals cold you want to let him go or
you know three guys sitting you go
is where's girls and all that we're that
you know that is totally hacky but it
kind of gets the crowd you know going
when you're in the mood but now people
don't buy into those jokes yeah it was a
realization of wow people really are PC
but it's a good thing like so I think
there is a legitimate reason to be PC
we're growing as people and and there
are things we don't accept any more we
don't accept racism anymore we don't
accept making jokes about gays anymore
and that's a good thing i think the
comedians that say oh it's to pc to pc
they might be correct but in other words
maybe you need to change to yes it's me
touch it there's an idea that's
interesting because Sarah Silverman said
something to that effect this week in an
interview and I think she was directing
it at Seinfeld because Seinfeld
basically was saying you know I used to
make this gay joke about a French King
and his loose you know his hand like
this and now they think it's too
offensive but I would always viewer on
this I don't know but you took all
Seinfeld politically incorrect I don't
know what he thinks about anything you
know what guys I know things about any
did you hear what he said about that
cotton ball yes exactly alright so my
way my final one final thought about
this because there's comes a time right
like so now we've come a long way with
how gay people are treated in our
society in a positive way but there's
guys who were born in a certain age like
Alec Baldwin they grew up using gay
terms as slurs and insults right and
then when that lizard brain gets
activated when you're angry at someone
those things come up right and so Alec
Baldwin got in trouble for calling a guy
a right he said he
called him a Fathead right
cuz apparently gender
neutral but no one swears like that no
one nobody says a four-dollar swear word
and then follows it up with a cartoon
nobody goes all you mother fart
snorkel right right so that's so do you
sure you give those people a little bit
of a leash then if you grew I can look
yeah yeah I especially if he apologizes
or lies or lies about it like I'll
involved with dick right know if he
apologizes look my dad said racist
things when I was growing up my dad
would never do it now but he's your dad
Bull Connor noise haha but when I was
growing up as a 27 year old man or 30
year old man he said stuff and my
brother and me would be like during and
now he would never do that because
everyone grows at a different rate you
know people are learning at different
ages and you know yeah all right so I
apologize at least though yeah so I
thought that the the right way to end
something with comedians would be to
talk about counterculture a little bit
because counterculture is what you know
stand up grew out of right it used to be
cool to fight the system yes and I feel
like it's not cool to fight the system
anymore you're thought of as crazy or
something or something I think it has a
lot to do with that most comics are
liberal most comics really at least at
the beginning really liked Obama so
everybody would say yeah it's tough to
make jokes about this guy because he's
rational and speaks clearly and he's not
making all the grammatical errors that
Bush was making now it's changed and I
think people don't necessarily like
Obama as much or at least people on the
left that feel that he's you know been
more right wing I think certainly that's
what you think so but we don't have a
real counterculture anymore how do we
need a republican in office to have a
true counterculture Wow would that
actually help the country people to have
someone that I believe in nothing that
they actually stand for the argument
that would strangle the argument has
been made that Barack Obama being the
head of the government right now splits
the opposition because they're the
people so we should be opposing him
about the indefinite detention TPP you
know all that stuff that Syria war with
you you want yeah maybe yeah we've known
everybody know you and I are on the same
page on this a week so what by Barack
Obama being the head of the government
he splits the opposition because half
the people are loyal to him and then the
other half the people are telling the
truth are wanting to push back and
protest against you know a tyrannical
government or that they see in
the government and so it doesn't happen
that's exactly what's happening and that
is what happened and that's why there is
no counterculture good interview to pick
up on it I get a couple every episode I
get one or two yeah have you ever bring
us on bring us well i was watching bill
maher the other night and he was of
course making fun of republicans in
george pataki was on there and it's
gotten to the point where yeah you want
to have one republican in the mix when
you're talking politics and doing the
counterculture thing all that but even
George Pataki is like well
party and it's just an indication of
we've just all moved to the right right
so maybe we do need a Republican office
to wake up the people to actually
realize what's important yes and and it
would be at least be good for comedians
all right on that note I want to thank
Felicia Michaels jimmy dore you can
follow them on twitter and youtube and
websites they got all that stuff and
we're gonna put my move it right beneath
you and Jimmy's got a book it's called
your country's just not that into you
yeah available bellmore all books are
sold everywhere there you go all right
thanks for watching guys and we will do
it again next week